elle n'est pas du tout aussi l'humain
nos parents nous ont pas laissés
d'argent hugo roux n'a pas de parents
les malheureux alors on aimerait bien
aller au cinéma pour aller voir les
amours sénat où la française elle avoue
bien le cauchemar de trac bien
[Musique]
16 bat pas assez alors merci bien
et puis nous on y va toujours totale au
cinéma
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai quand même c'est bien
normal de voir envie d'aller seul au
cinéma vous pouvez pas les voir en face
ionienne
on voulait père à vos plats si vous y
tenez
[Musique]
ans
c'est dommage on aurait bien aimé en et
ana au cinéma
[Musique]
oui mais le soir nous les payons place
publique au bout du nez
[Musique]
la maison
oh
tranquillement
ça
à
[Musique]
et quand on tombe sur des cartons qui
vous emmène vraiment
apprenez un agent
paquet
on aime
[Musique]
en tout les noms
mais malheur
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
tranquillement